Colin Firth The King's Speech
I'm afraid I have to warn you that I'm
experiencing stirrings
some in the upper abdominals which are
threatening to form themselves into
dance moves
um which uh
joyous as they may be for me
um it would be extremely problematic if
they
make it to my legs before I get off
stage so to the anglo-italian
American Canadian access which makes up
my family and Olivia for putting up with
my fleeting delusions of royalty and um
who I hold responsible for this and for
really everything that's good that's
happened since I met her now I feel well
excuse me I have some impulses I have to
tend to Backstage
[Music]
[Applause]